[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNY BROWN: Hi, there.
Jenny here.
I'm a sales trainer
for Google Cloud.
HEATHER CROSS: And I'm Heather.
Good to have you back, Jenny.
So today we're
going to be talking
about the internet
of things, or IoT.
JENNY BROWN: It
sounds pretty generic
if you're unfamiliar
with this term,
but we're surrounded by
this technology every day.
HEATHER CROSS: That's right.
So on this episode, we look
at Google Cloud IoT Core,
a managed service
to help securely
connect and manage
IoT devices at scale.
JENNY BROWN: Make
sure to stick around
for our quick demo of the
self-paced lab on Cloud IoT
Core.
Put simply, IoT
is taking devices
that were not traditionally
connected to the internet
and then adding internet
connectivity to them.
Why?
Because data is being created
all the time from devices,
applications, and their users.
By adding connectivity, a wealth
of data that was traditionally
offline becomes actionable.
HEATHER CROSS: Cloud IoT Core
is a fully managed service
that allows you to easily
and securely connect, manage,
and ingest data from up to
millions of globally dispersed
IoT devices.
The service is
server-less, and it
doesn't require any upfront
software installation.
It also scales instantly
with the horizontal scaling
of Google Cloud Platform.
JENNY BROWN: Cloud
IoT Core provides
a way of creating
a registry where
you can define where devices
are and then connect them.
Device telemetry data is
forwarded to a Cloud Pub/Sub
topic.
You can then use Cloud
Functions to trigger API calls,
or you can use DataFlow to
extract that data from Pub/Sub
and put it into a data
warehouse, such as Bigtable
or BigQuery.
This will allow you
to analyze and react
that data in real time.
HEATHER CROSS: So let's
jump into Qwik Labs.
You can check out the link
to start the Qwik Lab here.
You'll need to set aside about
40 minutes to complete it.
JENNY BROWN: This
hands-on lab will show you
how to use Google Cloud Platform
console to create a Cloud IoT
Core device registry,
connect a device,
and publish device
telemetry events.
So far in the lab, we've
created a device registry
with a Cloud Pub/Sub topic for
publishing device telemetry
events.
We then added a
device to the registry
and added a public
key to the device
so that it can connect to GCP.
We did some setup
to run a Node.js
sample to connect a virtual
device and view telemetry.
Once at this stage, we'll run
this command in Cloud Shell
to create a subscription to
the registry's Pub/Sub topic.
Then we run this command
to connect a virtual device
to Cloud IoT Core
using the MQTT Bridge.
The output shows that the sample
device is publishing messages
to the telemetry topic.
25 messages are published.
Finally, we run this command
to read the messages published
to the telemetry topic.
We created a Cloud
IoT Core device
registry, connected a device,
and published device telemetry
events.
HEATHER CROSS: We hope
you enjoyed this episode
as much as we did.
And don't forget, GCP
offers a 12-month free trial
with $300 in credits so you can
apply what you've learned today
and start using
it with your data.
JENNY BROWN: In addition,
there are resources for you
to take advantage of to
learn even more about cloud
technology and GCP.
Check out all the links
in the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER CROSS: Thanks
again for watching,
and we'll see you soon.